en este vídeo quiero presentarles un
tipo especial de espejos llamado espejo
espejo
árbol y co
lo genial de estos espejos y voy a
dibujar una sección transversal de este
tipo de espejos
si ustedes ya habían álgebra van a saber
que la sección transversal es una
parábola
dibujamos esta parábola aquí y no voy a
describir la matemática involucrada solo
les daré la idea general voy a dibujar
el eje principal de esta parábola
y les recuerdo que esto es un corte
transversal si nosotros pudiéramos ver
el espejo completo sería más o menos así
una
una abertura y aquí es como un tazón
pero con forma de parábola lo genial de
los espejos parabólicos es que al tener
rayos de luz que entran de manera
paralela al eje principal por ejemplo
tengo aquí un rayo de luz que va aquí
para el eje principal
llega a que el espejo y el momento de
tocar va a ser reflejado de esta manera
va a caer más o menos aquí y en un
momento les voy a decir cuál es lo
genial de esto vamos a dibujar otro rayo
de luz paralelo a este eje principal así
y va a rebotar así dibujamos otro rayo
ahora viene por acá sigue siendo
paralelo al eje se refleja así lo genial
de esto es que cualquier rayo incidente
que sea paralelo a este eje no importa
como venga o de donde caiga siempre y
cuando sea paralelo se va a reflejar y
va a llegar a este punto de acá que le
llamamos foco de la parábola este
es el foco de esta parábola imaginen que
quieren capturar el calor del sol y
tratar de concentrar lo en un solo punto
ustedes pueden ir a la mitad del
desierto y de hecho existen personas que
hacen esto en la realidad
y toman un espejo parabólico y lo
dirigen hacia donde se encuentra el sol
el sol se encuentra tan lejos que sus
rayos de luz y calor para cuando
alcanzan la superficie de la tierra
llegan de forma paralela así que estos
son los rayos del sol y lo genial es que
si estos rayos caen paralelos al eje de
esta parábola pues se van a reflejar
hacia el foco este radio de aquí se va a
reflejar acá
este radio de acá va a caer se refleja
aquí este rayo cae acá se refleja acá
por lo que toda la energía será
reflejada y concentrada en un solo punto
como en este ejemplo podríamos usar toda
esta energía para lo mejor hervir agua o
cocinar algo es una forma algo geek de
construir una estufa o quizá ustedes
quieran disipar energía y emitirla con
rayos paralelos imaginen que tenemos el
faro de un coche si yo dibujara un auto
voy a hacer mi mejor esfuerzo por
dibujar algo parecido a un auto esta es
la ventanilla donde están los pasajeros
aquí está la parte del frente esta es la
defensa
aquí va la llanta etc
y pueden imaginar algo muy curioso pero
imaginen que aquí adelante tengo
una bombilla un foco de luz
que va a estar encendido y va a estar
irradiando luz en todas direcciones y en
este caso aparte de deslumbrar al
conductor pues vamos a tener mucho
desperdicio de energía ya que la mayoría
de la luz va a iluminar otras partes que
no me interesa a mí me interesa que esta
luz ilumine el camino por dónde va a
pasar el auto
como podemos dirigir la luz pues usando
espejos parabólicos voy a reemplazar
este foco que no está muy bonito de acá
y voy a dibujar un espejo parabólico un
poco más grande de lo que sería en
realidad pero para que nos quede claro
qué es lo que va a pasar entonces voy a
dibujar aquí un espejo parabólico
en el punto focal de esta parábola voy a
dibujar un foco un foco de luz
qué va a ocurrir bueno este foco va a
irradiar luz en todas direcciones los
rayos de luz que vayan hacia esta parte
me van a ser útiles porque están
iluminando lo que a mí me interesa el
camino del auto
pero todos aquellos rayos de luz que
están iluminando
en otras direcciones lo genial de este
espejo parabólico es que van a ser
reflejados de manera paralela al eje
principal de esta parábola todos estos
rayos de luz serán enviados hacia
adelante paralelamente al eje principal
de manera que toda esta luz me va a ser
útil para iluminar el camino de este
auto
otra cosa interesante de los espejos
parabólicos es que forman imágenes
reales en el vídeo anterior hablamos
sobre el concepto de imagen virtual en
donde daba la impresión de que existe
algo dentro del espejo pero son solo los
rayos de luz reflejados que nuestro
cerebro hace converger hacia un punto
pero en realidad no existe el objeto en
ese lugar su luz simplemente fue
reflejada voy a hacer algo de espacio
aquí porque voy a dibujar un gran espejo
parabólico
así más o menos
con su eje principal que vamos a ver de
perfil
y pongo unos puntos interesantes voy a
dibujar aquí el punto focal este que lo
llamo efe el foco el punto focal de esta
parábola y también voy a dibujar un
punto que se llama el centro de
curvatura este lo pongo acá se llama ce
centro de curvatura y un dato
interesante es que este centro de
curvatura va a estar al doble de
distancia que el punto focal si de aquí
a acá yo llamo a esta distancia
efe voy a tener otra cantidad igual de
distancia aquí otra
efe entre comillas entonces se encuentra
en mi centro de curvatura y esto se mide
a partir del vértice o del punto mínimo
de esta parábola lo que quiero hacer es
poner un objeto en frente de este espejo
y ver qué sucede vamos a ir con la
convención de que los objetos se dibujan
como flechas
y la punta de la flecha indica en donde
termina el objeto este es un objeto no
un rayo de luz este objeto va a ser
iluminado por una fuente de luz que no
sabemos dónde está y va a reflejar dicha
luz de manera difusa es decir este
objeto no es algo brilloso voy a elegir
un punto de esta imagen para que emita
luz de manera radial y ver qué sucede
con estos rayos como recomendación
siempre que tengamos diagramas con
espejos parabólicos siempre es bueno
dibujar un rayo que vaya paralelo al eje
principal y otro rayo que pase por el
foco por supuesto estos son solo dos
rayos de los millones de rayos de luz
que puede estar emitiendo está
reflejando en cada uno de estos puntos
del objeto hacemos esto para comprender
cómo se verá la imagen de este objeto
así que dibujamos aquí desde este punto
vamos a dibujar un rayo que va a ser
paralelo al eje principal más o menos
así que sabemos que cuando se refleje va
a pasar por el foco así más o menos
ahora voy a dibujar otro rayo de luz que
sale de la misma fuente vamos a ponerle
el otro colorcito un rosita y ahora este
rayo de luz va a salir
y ahora va a pasar por el punto focal
va a rebotar y sabemos que este va a
rebotar de manera paralela a este eje
principal que está pasando aquí
ambos rayos fueron emitidos desde el
mismo punto en este objeto flecha van a
emitir luz radialmente hacia afuera y se
va a reflejar en este espejo parabólico
y aunque van a reflejarse de manera
diferente van a converger en un mismo
punto si hacemos esto con todos los
puntos de la flecha como por ejemplo en
esta base este rayo bueno va a ir ahora
así que sobre el eje principal y va a
rebotar aquí de manera que va a quedar
en esta zona si hacemos esto para todos
los rayos de luz que son emitidos
difusamente y radialmente por este
objeto nos va a quedar que en este punto
de acá
va a haber un reflejo una imagen
del objeto si aquí pusiéramos una
pantalla no sé a lo mejor una lona
blanca o un muro justo aquí aquí
pusiéramos una pantalla
pantalla
y esta imagen fuera reflejada en esta
pantalla a esta imagen la llamaríamos
imagen real
está
estar acá sería una imagen real imagen
real entre comillas
si la comparamos con la imagen virtual
esta es una imagen que parece que viene
de cierto lugar pero que no es así solo
luce como se divirtiera de ese punto
pero solo en la luz que fue reflejada en
cambio una imagen real va a ser una
imagen que puede ser proyectada que al
chocar contra la pantalla va a difundir
luz de la misma manera que lo haría el
objeto real
en la pantalla veremos a este objeto
espero que esto les haya sido útil y
hablaremos más sobre espejos parabólicos
en el siguiente vídeo